[Music]
hey everybody and welcome back to my
arabian free fly coaster experiment now
as you might notice i've been doing some
off-camera stuff and i have to say this
is something that's going to be a
recurring theme throughout this series
normally i don't like to do too many
things off camera i actually prefer to
figure out what it is exactly that i've
been doing
that actually stays in the park and try
to record all of that and edit that
together so for example there will be
times when i'm building something and it
ends up not being used or scrapped for
something else i think it's reasonable
to cut that kind of footage but when
important stuff gets done i usually try
to show it off but in this case i think
it's probably good to
try a different approach because
especially with the first section of the
coaster layout here i've been
experimenting so much and in general
this entire build is going to take a lot
of off camera just
rotating around figuring out what kind
of sight lines i want to build and
things like that and i think there's
just certain types of things that you
tend to do or at least that i tend to do
in the game that aren't very conducive
to recording time lapses and making it
look decent
because i'm trying to
move the camera around as little as
possible whenever i'm recording these
time lapses which works fairly well for
when you're trying to build buildings or
come up with a dome structure like i'm
doing right now
but it doesn't work very well for when
you're trying to figure out the layout
of a park or messing with ideas before
you're actually building something
which is something that i really do like
to do because one of the worst things
that you can ever have is
building a building and putting all of
the details in and working everything
out and then realizing that it's too big
for the space or it just doesn't work
out or you don't see it from certain
parts of the park that you do want to
see it from so working out composition
and sight lines and stuff like that well
still something uh will still be
something that i'm gonna keep doing off
camera another thing is um the start of
the layouts of the coaster here i was
trying to come up with ideas on what to
do with the dark ride section that's
gonna be the start of the ride and that
just took a lot of trial and error now
i know there's this whole meme about
youtubers doing things off camera i
swear i'm not going to do uh huge
monumental things and suddenly show you
a castle that wasn't there before
but stuff like that will happen in the
future so
and by stuff like that i mean smaller
things and mostly moving stuff around
anyway let's talk for a second about
what i'm building here because i wanted
to build as much of a symmetrical layout
to these buildings as possible given the
fact that this part of the coaster
layout
is also symmetrical but at the same time
i wanted the tower at the front to
really be the centerpiece of this whole
cluster of buildings and towers and to
be the small local weenie of this area
so for this tower i'm going for a
similar size but a slightly different
shape it's completely round and it has a
a dome i guess yeah on top of it but
it's not a very fancy dome and it's not
a very tall dome and something that i
realized in hindsight but wasn't really
the intent of this tower but it works
out perfectly is that this dome actually
might help transition
this themed area into the next themed
land
because as you might know i am trying to
make the transitions between themed
areas as smooth as possible in this map
and make
certain areas where you're not pulled
out of the immersion by a sudden
different theme appearing out of nowhere
and part of the solution to that is
going to be trying different
variations of a theme within an area and
using those to blend from one part of an
area to another and this is gonna have
some kind of real world
geography connotations as well so to
give you an example
this dome that i just built i figured
that it might actually fit into that
area because it's a little bit
reminiscent of ottoman domes
which
unlike persian domes or
say mugaw architecture from india they
don't tend to feature those onion shapes
but instead they're just regular
semi-circles
and ottoman domes used to also be
made with terracotta tiles and later on
uh more lead tiles and stuff like that
it's just that the material use and the
shape reminds me a bit of an ottoman
dome rather than the persian theming
which this area is supposed to have and
i think that's probably a good thing
because around that part of the park i'm
going to build an ottoman-themed land at
some point to transition to
another future themed land
and by the way if this all sounds really
strange and like i'm planning a park and
not just this ride and this area here
that's because i'm trying to build this
ride in such a way that it could
seamlessly transition into a park if i
ever get to
finish it and
go far enough with this that it's gonna
turn into a proper park i think one of
the biggest mistakes that i made with
fantasy valley
aka the park that i built the b m flying
coaster suzaku in is that from the
outset i made it into a park and it
never really ended up being finished
even though i was happy with
the area that i did finish with suzaku
in it
but to this day people are still asking
me when i'm gonna reboot fantasy valley
and
at this point i'm thinking it might
actually be a better
approach to just build certain rides and
make a themed land around it and make
them fit into each other in such a way
that i could make a park out of it at
some point in the future and trust me i
am laying down the foundations and the
composition of this park already as we
speak
but i'm not going to promise anytime
soon that i will actually finish this
because the more i work on this themed
land on its own the more i start to
realize that
i want to make
building this into a park an option but
not a necessity so for now i'm going to
stick with this area but do keep in mind
that i'm planning to connect this to a
whole
big park and in that park there's going
to be an ottoman section to transition
from the arabian themed land into the
european themed land because if i think
there's any kind of architecture that
can kind of fit into both of these
categories it's ottoman architecture
because they do have those minarets and
the domes that you see a lot of it in in
arabian architecture they had a huge
influence over the middle east in
general
but also you can find a lot of ottoman
inspired architecture in europe
especially greece and the balkans and i
think from there you can really
transition into a european themed land
without having a drastic change where
everything suddenly switches and you go
through a gate and suddenly you're in a
very different land which i don't think
there's anything wrong with that but i
would really love to try in this park to
make those transitions as seamless as
possible and i think from a geography
standpoint it would be really cool as
well because
at that point you're traveling from
persia towards europe and you're going
through a small ottoman themed section
and then ending up in greece or albania
or something like that and it's like
having a microcosm of traveling from the
middle east to europe in the theme park
in terms of the themes that you're gonna
be walking through and
i feel like that would be really cool
there are so many theme parks in the
world that already trying to emulate the
themes of different countries uh but not
really put them on a
uh on a sort of geography geographical
composition where it could make real
life sense it's like you're making a a
small journey through the world on a
miniature version of it at least so
that's kind of what i'm planning uh here
and that's why i was pretty happy with
that domed building in hindsight because
i'm gonna put some ottoman themed
buildings right across the road from it
so that's probably gonna help transition
into that part
[Music]
so this next section of time lapse is
pretty important for me i think this was
the section where i realized that this
was a theme that was going to be doable
that i could do on a large scale and
that i could theme this entire coaster
because truth be told until now i was
building these towers around the coaster
but i had no idea how to theme the rest
of this area how it would be laid out
and how it would even work so i was
still
unsure if this was really going to be
continued if this was
going to be
something decent
um but at this point i started building
some facades as a show building cover
because we do have a dark ride section
here at the start just a few turns it's
nothing major it's kind of like the
flying dutchman uh except even shorter
than that but i really like the idea
of starting off the coaster experience
with a small dark ride section
especially on this coaster because well
the theme and the story are where i put
the emphasis so i think it makes more
sense than going straight into the lift
hill but because of that this ride kind
of sits in the middle of the park and
it is sort of toward the edge but
there's a lot of show building that i'm
gonna have to cover which is
not the most
handy thing typically as a very heavily
themed theme park if you look for
instance on google maps at disney or
universal parks you'll see that they
have
smaller buildings that are the themed
buildings that you think you're going
into and then hidden behind those
smaller buildings they have huge
buildings where they house the actual
dark rides and roller coasters i think
phantom manor in disneyland paris does
an amazing job at this i think all of
the haunted mansions uh from disney in
general do a really good job at this at
making you feel like you're just going
into a small building and then using the
interior of that building and i'm not
gonna give any spoilers but there are
some really cool tricks there to
disorient people and make them not
realize that they're actually going into
a very big show building that they hid
at the back with some trees in front of
it or scenery in front of it or
something like that
so that's usually what you would do as a
theme park to hide your giant dark ride
buildings but in this case
i think it's actually a decent idea to
have this thing right here kind of in
the middle of the park
because it gives me an excuse to build
lots of
sort of simple but
theme setting buildings here so there
are going to be a few facades here in
this
arabian persian style that i was trying
to mess around with
and it's kind of the the proof of
concept for this whole theme because i
really want to make it feel like you're
in a big city with lots of buildings
around you and some minarets some wind
catchers and a huge musk perhaps
somewhere
so this is all part of that so these
buildings are not going to be buildings
that you can enter they're purely
cosmetic
which i guess is a little bit lame
preferably you do want to have some
planes of buildings that you can
actually open and that people can use as
restaurants or restrooms or something
like that but in this case i need so
many buildings in this area to
convincingly give that city vibe
and i'm only gonna have two coasters uh
some bathrooms at some point a
restaurant and a souvenir shop at least
that's my planning so far so there's
only gonna be so many buildings that are
actually gonna have a function so i'm
definitely gonna have to place some
buildings that don't have a
a function at least not from street
level that people can enter so using
this dark right section to add lots of
just
huge building space into this area and
trying to make it seem as much as
possible like there are all kinds of
different smaller building facades i
think it's a decent solution at
achieving that city look and
to come back to the whole rant that i
started this part of the video with
that's kind of how this felt like a
proof of concept for me because i wasn't
really sure if this big wall of arabian
inspired buildings was really going to
work out but in the end i think it does
pretty well and i'm pretty happy with it
and it was also compared to the other
building so far a really good test of
the theme maker's toolkit items
especially the decals and i think they
make a huge difference in terms of how
these buildings look they really come
out and make this stucco look more
interesting
and textured so
yeah i'm pretty happy with this so far
[Music]
now at this point i kept the in-game
paths as sort of a placeholder until i
figured out what i wanted to do with
this area
and at some point i realized what might
be fun to try is to do one of those big
concrete tile things
there are lots of theme parks that have
big concrete tiles that are colored and
slightly discolored at this point in
time and that was a look that i really
wanted to try and figure out how it
could work in planet coaster so
these big stucco pieces that i'm using
for this are not super textured but by
putting a bunch of them together and
giving them all slightly different
colors and rotating them around a bit i
think you can make an interesting enough
texture and that's what i ended up doing
over here so this is going to be my path
style for this whole arabian part of the
park
as per usual usually if you look at
disney parks universal parks or any
heavily themed
theme parks in general
usually you'll have different colors and
textures of parts per area so that's one
of the easiest ways to tell where you
are so
as for me i'm going to stick with this
color and texture for the arabian part
and then trying to see where i can
switch to other path styles in different
parts of the park
but this is going to be it here
the only thing that
kind of irks me about it in hindsight is
these pieces for some reason their lods
disappear very quickly when you zoom out
so i ended up raising these parts quite
a bit
which looks alright if there aren't any
people walking around but when there are
people walking around you can definitely
see the soles of their feet
kind of sinking into the path covers and
i know in planet coaster that's kind of
a given that's something that you
usually have to deal with but in this
case it's a little bit more noticeable
so
not entirely sure how much of a fan i am
of this look i will turn all of these
parts into a single building at some
point in the future because i forgot to
do that at this point and
well once it's a it's a one building i
can always try to raise and lower it
according to what i think looks decent
and i won't have to put too much time
into that but still it's uh it's a
little bit iffy but moving on from uh
the path discussion here's an
interesting tidbit where i'm trying to
build a persian inspired fountain that
was
originally i was thinking of doing
persian gardens somewhere which are very
geometrically shaped gardens typically
with
large plazas or buildings or palaces
around them or on one side of them but
in the end i don't think that type of
garden works out very well for a theme
park so maybe i can do some persian
inspired gardening somewhere um
and for now i'm going to stick with this
pal with this fountain which is
something that you'll often find in
persian gardens they'll have these long
stretches of fountains
throughout the middle or the size or
wherever
throughout these geometric gardens and
this particular shape i actually don't
know what it's called but it's uh it's a
very particular shape if this style of
architecture
is something that i figured if i'm gonna
have a fountain somewhere in the area it
has to be this one and it's kind of a
shame we don't have it in the game
because it is a pretty common shape for
fountains in general
so i figured i would build my own
the only challenge with this turned out
to be that there's no way to fill this
thing with water obviously the middle is
actually made out of another fountain
piece so that has its proper water
texture and all but the actual lower
part of the fountain there's no way to
actually fill this thing so
i kind of forgot about that when i was
building this thing and truth be told i
was pretty excited for how well it was
working out all of these different
textured and themed pieces actually work
pretty well together and you can make
some pretty fancy classical looking
stuff with them
um but yeah that water is definitely
going to be a challenge so
there you see me cutting uh from doing
some off-screen footage i was looking at
that fountain and trying to come up with
ideas for what to do with it for way too
long until i eventually decided to just
put some bushes in there which
i think it works alright although it
wasn't my idea because recently as you
know i was in disneyland paris and at
the ratatouille section they also have a
fountain with flowers and bushes in it
instead of water and i think it looks
pretty cool so
it wasn't really my original idea to do
with this fountain but now that i'm
looking at it and you see all this
greenery
i think it's a really nice touch
especially given the fact that all of
the buildings around this area are all
very beige and brown same goes for the
pot texture which it's a lot of brown
shades of brown um it's something that i
ended up going with anyway because i
think it conveys that sense of desert
quite well even when the rest of this
park is quite temperate and there's a
lot of foliage so i'm still pretty happy
with it but it's it's a lot of brown
it's not so many nice lush colors so
adding this green in there was uh
worked out pretty well i think in the
end it looks better than water would
have had would have looked anyway so
and moving on from that i i'm going to
finish this whole row of buildings here
with some more facades which is pretty
fun because at this point i really kind
of have my
uh my my workflow completed for these
and that is just to make a rectangular
part of the facade with stucco walls
give it a slightly different color than
the other one so you get some color
variation in the buildings
add a door at some windows
preferably also some oreo windows here
and there it's something that you'll
find a lot in middle eastern
architecture
be it egyptian or persian or whatever is
these windows that juts out are made out
of wood and hang over the streets
sometimes you'll even have entire floors
of buildings hanging over the streets so
that's definitely something that i'm
going to add to a lot of the buildings
in this area
and finally i'm going to build another
wind catcher here which was always the
plan for this corner there's just
something about corners and adding
what we call in dutch
accent and i don't know what a good
english word for it would be but
typically on the corners of a row of
building facades it's it's nice to add a
something taller and something for
the eye to look at and
see as the
focal focal point of that whole area and
i think this wind catcher does a pretty
good job at doing that without being too
over the top
i think once you start adding domes on
corner buildings you're going uh
kind of off from the actual way that
this theme should be done i think
adding too many domes like i said in the
first episode i think is one of the
biggest pitfalls that you can have when
you're doing an arabian themed area not
that there's anything wrong with it
if you're into it and it looks cool i
i'd guess why the hell not
but in this case i'm trying to be a
little bit more realistic than that and
trying to conserve my dome usage for
when it actually counts
um so yeah
staying within the theme of the
buildings that i already have i'm trying
to come up with ways to make some
slightly custom windows and doors as
well
to not make everything look too much the
same
um and there are lots of wooden pieces
in the game that work really well for it
even in game pieces there's
no use for using theme maker toolkit
items for things like this i think
and also something that i didn't touch
on in the first episode but i think is
fun to point out as well i'm just adding
some bricks into the stucco layers here
and there to give the idea of
these being
brick buildings that were
stuccoed over or
you can see some of the structures
peeking through the the surface layer of
these buildings and the same goes for
some of the decal pieces as well which
work really well to give that sort of
weathered
slightly dilapidated look
[Music]
finally it was time for me to do some
finishing touches around the area and
first thing that kind of irked me and
that i wanted to fix was the exit out
from the show building
and
gosh this coaster type is kind of
annoying when it comes to things like
this because these trains are so wide
it's really hard to just make a small
hole in this building and make it look
decent and you know be a regular exit no
instead of that you have these
multiple meter wide vehicles and even
worse there's two of them so i have to
make these huge holes in this building
to even let those things go out so to
kind of hide these holes i built that
smaller building um right on the plaza
that i was just putting all of these
facades in to try and make these giant
holes as invisible as possible from
street level
because it's going to be a bit weird if
you can look into the whole dark right
section of the coaster but yeah that's a
challenge that i am willing to deal with
it's part of
what i signed up to building these types
of coasters but it's definitely
something to keep in mind and at some
point in the future you know these
coasters are going to have to re-enter
a building when they come back into the
station
and i'm definitely going to have to
think about how i'm going to dress that
up in some way where you can slowly get
used to the dark as well when you're
riding these coasters and to not make
the entry back into the building look
too weird it's definitely gonna require
some special attention i think as
opposed to just making some halls in
buildings
now finally
and this was the most boring part of
this whole
video i think it's definitely the part
that i was procrastinating on and it's a
good reason it's the last part of this
time lapse i had to do the backside of
these buildings and while there's not
going to be going too much attention to
this area i really wanted to have some
finished backsides as well so just
putting in some final details a few
buildings here and there and some
foliage and at some point in the future
but this is going to be in many many
episodes because as we speak i have no
plans to tackle this anytime soon but at
some point in the future there's going
to be a small path winding down
this side of the building and going
right underneath the red coasters
layouts
speaking of which i haven't come up with
how i'm going to divide the names of
these coasters but
one of them is gonna be the caliph and
one of them is gonna be uh the vizier
but
um i'll decide which which is which at
some point in the future but for now
there's gonna be a path uh going down
underneath the red one
so
i'm trying to make this area somewhat
future-proof but we'll come back to this
later for now it's not going to be too
interesting
all right now before i end this video i
want to give a quick real-time overview
of what i have so far
there's actually a few things that i
didn't showcase yet but
this is the start of the station
or however this is going to work but
this is definitely subject to change in
some of the future episodes do know for
now though that when i get to the
station it's going to be a bit of a
logistical challenge because we need to
get people in from both sides of both
tracks so that is four entrances and we
of course need to get the people out as
well and the reason for this is that of
course we have two dueling coasters that
you can only enter from one side of the
track
so there's gonna be a lot of uh stuff
involved with that
then there's this part of the building
which is reserved for a dark ride
portion
and as you can see these facades over
here are trying their hardest to hide
the fact that this is really a show
building but in a sense it also gives me
the opportunity to add lots of facades
and really establish a city-like
character to this whole area without
having to worry too much about what kind
of restaurants or rides or anything like
this is going to fit in here
and then we have the entrance of course
which i will detail a little bit more in
the future as you can see right now it
doesn't really have a ceiling
but as you can tell if you're on the
path over here this little building here
kind of hides where the lift hills have
to come out of
and then the lift hills themselves also
give a sort of scenic overview to uh
everybody who is down here and vice
versa as well i imagine that from the
lift hill you'll have a pretty cool view
of the track that you're about to ride
over here some of the towers around you
a palm tree over here that has a hitbox
that is smaller than the palm tree
itself so it disappears sometimes
but um
yeah this is uh basically the tower
structure at this point so as you can
see we have all of these beams
going into these towers at the same
angles
which supposedly is to hide the fact
that there's really a large metal beam
in the middle of the tower which is
supporting all of this weight
but then of course these also kind of
have a
thematic uh function as well i hope you
don't hear the kids screaming outside in
which case
i'm sorry it definitely sounds like
something horrible is going down out
there but
i'm sure they're doing fine anyway um so
as you can see here uh there's a bit of
a strange support over here trying to
support this catwalk portion
which is also themed a little bit not
exactly sure to what but at least it's
something fun to interact with and over
here as well it gives some really
interesting head shoppers and food
choppers i guess as well
but i think that's enough talking about
these rides themselves i think you guys
have been uh
been killing for me to finally write
these things and give a small pov i saw
some comments in the previous video
where people were asking for some povs
and i have to say for now
i can't give you guys a full pov because
i haven't even finished the whole layout
yet i have no idea what i'm gonna do
over here but for now i think aprv of
one side
of everything that i have so far is
probably fair so this is all
going to be future dark ride stuff
definitely gonna clean it up at some
point in the future and here we have the
lift hill as you can see it's not even a
very big coaster i believe this lift
hole is only a little over 12 or 15 or
so meters tall
it's not very large
and then over here as we pass the tower
here we start flipping to the other side
there's a pretty heavy swing over here
as we flip back and go through this
mid-course brake run and then over here
the two trains will come together at the
same time and they'll be synchronized as
they go over this little
i'm not even sure what to call it but
the combined light to fly element that
you have over here
um i just noticed that i think there's
something wrong with the synchronization
of these trains oh well that will be
fixed in the future so don't worry about
that but uh you'll get to see them
actually dual in glory
if all goes right then these first
sections of course will be symmetrical
so they'll be
just as fast so they'll be dueling up
until this point
then of course uh purple gets the inner
curve over here so it manages to get
some headway and then it's the higher
point on this light to fly elements so
then red will make up some speed
and uh they'll be
hopefully uh going down this drop right
at the same time as i'm trying to get a
good perspective of it
and then uh into whatever comes after
this also a good thing to keep in mind
is that for the station i'm planning a
pretty big monumental building and over
here we'll have a bridge
going over the coaster tracks and up to
the station so that'll be a cool sight
line and also some fun path interactions
so they'll be crossing over the paths
over here
into another break run and then uh down
below the paths and then this area
around here uh can be themed with some
buildings and foliage to really complete
the city square area over here
so yeah that is basically all of my
plans for this coaster
i will
slightly raise these path textures
because as you can see when you zoom out
they're glitching a little bit but i'll
fix that in the future as well
and for now that's gonna be it hopefully
i'll see you guys in the next episode
where i'll be working on the station
area and i hope you guys enjoyed this
video as well thanks for watching and
i'll see you next time